[Music]
Animal cadavers are bad not just because
they won't wants live animals but
because once the tissues are frozen and
or preserved they're not the same
anymore so they don't feel the same they
don't perform the same and you know this
product is going to give them you know
more of a lifelike experience
[Music]
this endeavor canine is going to be a
highly complex system that mimics every
part of the animal and you're going to
be able to do a lot of different things
with it trauma training space
veterinarians will be able to train in
brain surgery with no risk of the animal
because they've got this platform to up
to training we can get into every vet
school maybe within the decade but if
we're successful in our fundraising we
can make it happen practically overnight
we'll be able to provide up to 20
canines to practically every accredited
Veterinary College in the world saving
tens of thousands of animals in the
process
[Music]